[SPEAKER_00]: Morning light is actually starting to shine through from the cave.
[SPEAKER_00]: And when I say morning light, it's obviously coming near dawn, but the sunrise is probably still an hour away or so.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I would say it's around 5 p.m.
[SPEAKER_00]: The four of the party members begin running down the platform towards the beach.
[SPEAKER_00]: That includes Tyrus in front, Gouge, next to him, Paul Rivero behind him, and then Folsom bringing up the rear.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude is on the ballista.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm also keeping an eye out and see if Fairwind's swimming around anywhere out here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then Merrick is...
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm also on the ballista with him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the way the ballista works is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: One person shoots it, but to fire a ballista it has to be loaded.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cocked back, and then fired.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are three actions that need to happen to fire it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So while they're moving, can we at least have like one round ready?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you get one round ready to go.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm just saying, my archery proficience might, does that come into play with the ballista?
[SPEAKER_05]: Or is it just kind of just so big that it doesn't matter?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, like should he be the one firing it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Proficiency matters.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm gonna pop in that seat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then I'll help you and you play.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have your bow ready though.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I'd have your bow ready.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, obviously dexterity matters, and you've got good dexterity.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I was gonna say.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm a plus four.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you have good dexterity too, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, yes I do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but your bow is probably...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, you can hit a lot of shots.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's re-disintegrated?
[SPEAKER_01]: How about if I help him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I help him or resist?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think what Tyrus is saying is that...
[SPEAKER_00]: A bow and a ballista firing at the same time is more effective than him on a ballista with you not shooting your bow.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hope you will load it up and I'll ready my arrows.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, perfect, perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we get it loaded up, I'm ready to shoot, and he's ready to shoot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Otherwise you're just standing there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you guys are running down to the docks.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, you get to about there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And sahaugin start coming out of the water.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sahaugin!
[SPEAKER_05]: Hey, that's the barrels.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: Isn't that cool?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so... Harry Potter.
[SPEAKER_01]: Brodhead, Ballista, those three right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so let's begin comment, but you guys were both on Overwatch, so if you want to fire right off the bat you can do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which one do you want to shoot at?
[SPEAKER_00]: Fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: How many are there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Five?
[SPEAKER_00]: You see five there.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do see five there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your bow should be right there.
[SPEAKER_05]: Plus your proficiency.
[SPEAKER_05]: Eight plus seven.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, yeah, that hits him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you hit one of this hog in with an arrow.
[SPEAKER_00]: He does not fall, but you wound him.
[SPEAKER_00]: You did get advantage, but
[SPEAKER_00]: You're at long range.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're far away, so it kind of evens out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I'm shooting the Ballista where I can get those three in a line.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you fire at this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: 18.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Ballista hits this guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now a Ballista does 6 die 10 worth of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_04]: Holy shit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Cut right through his ass.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, die ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's two of them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's another ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: How many?
[SPEAKER_00]: Another one?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, that's enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six die ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's seven.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six.
[SPEAKER_05]: Here we go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so that's...
[SPEAKER_00]: Seven, two, five.
[SPEAKER_03]: You count it out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Three, two, four, seven.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's nine, ten, that's sixteen, sixteen, seventeen, eighteen, nineteen, twenty, twenty-one, twenty-two, twenty-three.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that ballista sticks through the guy and kills him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Doesn't go through?
[SPEAKER_00]: So the way a ballista works is there's a line of attack, right, and you roll the hit points that you do, and then you roll to hit the guy that you're going through, and if the hit points are more than his hit points, it goes through.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you killed him.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you just killed him.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you had done 60, the 22 would have been minus from what is, and it would travel to the next guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it kind of like just cuts his chest in half and kind of digs into the ground at the other guy's heels.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it just sticks through him and stops in his body.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not that cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: A fireball would have been better.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, Anish.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ooh, they do hate fire.
[SPEAKER_03]: You could cast a wall of fire.
[SPEAKER_05]: Twenty-two for Folsom.
[SPEAKER_05]: Twenty-two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Folsom needs to quit being in the back.
[SPEAKER_05]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_05]: Nineteen for Gouge.
[SPEAKER_05]: Nine for Merrick.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine for Merrick.
[SPEAKER_03]: Twenty-two for Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty-two for Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: They get a six-eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Jude, what do you get?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, am I rolling?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Separate from the plus four?
[SPEAKER_00]: 17 plus four is 23.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude?
[SPEAKER_00]: 21.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: Folsom and Paul get to go first.
[SPEAKER_05]: Can I just, am I 60?
[SPEAKER_05]: Can I see him coming out of the water?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, you can see him.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right, let me use Vicious Mockery.
[SPEAKER_05]: Vicious Mockery.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's his saving throw.
[SPEAKER_00]: You silly fish.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five.
[SPEAKER_00]: He does not make it.
[SPEAKER_00]: You do a one die, four in damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come on, big money.
[SPEAKER_00]: I save.
[SPEAKER_00]: You bastard.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fuck you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Fuck you, fish brain.
[SPEAKER_05]: That would be a... Two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two.
[SPEAKER_00]: You do two points of damage to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he did not make his semi-throw, so he has disadvantage on attack next round.
[SPEAKER_05]: I hit him with my arrow earlier, correct?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, did you?
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so he has 11 total of him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not down yet.
[SPEAKER_05]: Alright, that is my turn.
[SPEAKER_05]: But he's depressed.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's very depressed.
[SPEAKER_05]: My words are as short as I die.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's me.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's vicious, actually.
[SPEAKER_05]: Who's turn is it?
[SPEAKER_03]: Paul is your turn.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll take my crossbow and can I shoot him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you load up your white crossbow and you fire.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I do the sneak attack?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you cannot because he's not near anybody and you don't have advantage on him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, just a raw roll of him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm 16k.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, shit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Might cross by me.
[SPEAKER_03]: 12 plus 4 is 16.
[SPEAKER_00]: That hits.
[SPEAKER_00]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: 1 die 8.
[SPEAKER_03]: 5 plus 4 is 9.
[SPEAKER_00]: 9.
[SPEAKER_00]: He falls.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hip hip!
[SPEAKER_04]: Is that extra two points pushing him over the edge?
[SPEAKER_02]: He stopped and went, be free.
[SPEAKER_01]: How long?
[SPEAKER_01]: Would it take me, like, alone?
[SPEAKER_01]: Would it take me two rounds to try to, like, rearm it alone?
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three rounds?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I'm gonna move to 5, 10, 15, 20, 25.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you gonna try and go down the thing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So where can I be at 30?
[SPEAKER_01]: So if I wanted to cast, I'd need to guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: You would still be 210 feet away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I'll dash.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you dash down this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's it?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's all you're going to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, because it's the Ballista's Dunsies.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow, that was lame.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are more Eros, but it would take you three rounds slower.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would take me three rounds.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your combat, I will be able in like one more round of dashing in my third round, I can fire a Bulge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or fire a Bulge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't move Tyrus in front of me.
[SPEAKER_00]: True, or if you want to, you can jump into the water.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I don't know if you want to do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you want to just crossbow, you could do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're pretty close.
[SPEAKER_01]: You crossbow.
[SPEAKER_05]: Everybody's on, stay out of the water.
[SPEAKER_05]: How far am I about the water?
[SPEAKER_00]: This is about five feet deep right there, and you drop down maybe five feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm going.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you step off and jump into the water about up to here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to move?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Move.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's going to be half movement.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, one, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to go there?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to... And get on to the shore?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you want to go one more to there with six?
[SPEAKER_00]: With your sword and your dagger out, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you want to save an action?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna go...
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dash.
[SPEAKER_00]: You want to dash?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: There we go.
[SPEAKER_00]: To there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Headed straight for the barrels.
[SPEAKER_05]: Going for the barrels.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I'm yelling, cover me!
[SPEAKER_05]: Uh, Merrick?
[SPEAKER_05]: Um, I'm gonna stay posted above.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm gonna reload, can I reload the...
[SPEAKER_05]: It takes you three rounds to do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: It will take you three rounds to do that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Which means you can fire three arrows.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm loading my bow up and ready to action.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you can shoot now.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh yeah, I'm gonna shoot whatever one closest one to me.
[SPEAKER_05]: That one.
[SPEAKER_05]: That guy?
[SPEAKER_05]: Fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fourteen plus.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus seven.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll damage, one die eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're getting three.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight plus three.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight plus three is eleven.
[SPEAKER_00]: That hits the guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does not take him down, but you definitely wound him.
[SPEAKER_00]: This one.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: He dies.
[SPEAKER_00]: They go.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy goes...
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five to here with his spear.
[SPEAKER_00]: He attacks.
[SPEAKER_00]: How many hit points do you have off you?
[SPEAKER_04]: I have 22 hit points right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Total?
[SPEAKER_00]: Total.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: He attacks you with advantage.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's blood crazed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's the attack with the spear.
[SPEAKER_00]: 18.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's my AC.
[SPEAKER_00]: 18 is your AC?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: That misses.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's his next attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: He tries to bite you.
[SPEAKER_00]: 13 miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he's just basically rushing at you, trying to kill you with a spear and biting at you.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy moves to here, Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Attacks you.
[SPEAKER_00]: How many AC do you have off you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Hit points off of me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have one hit point?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have one hit point off of you?
[SPEAKER_00]: He attacks you with advantage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Smelling your blood.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I'm definitely bleeding.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ten, what's your AC?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: His bite.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sixteen, you said it's your AC?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, his bite basically is stopped by your set of leather armor, but just barely.
[SPEAKER_00]: His mouth grabs onto you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's my...
[SPEAKER_02]: Saved attack, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You got another one.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have a saved action.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to attack him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: You should have done that first.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's my fault.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, my bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you slash at him with your attack.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Scimitar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two.
[SPEAKER_02]: That'll be a miss.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is a mess.
[SPEAKER_02]: And my dagger.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't get that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_02]: What was my bonus?
[SPEAKER_02]: I only save.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't get a bonus save.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can do a saved action, but you don't get a bonus attack.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy comes to here and attacks you, too.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Spear.
[SPEAKER_00]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bite.
[SPEAKER_00]: 18 hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: You take three, four, five points of damage as his fangs, his shark teeth sink into your arm.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I only take four because that's it for the bard shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: So now that's four into me.
[SPEAKER_02]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you near death, well bloodied, or lightly wounded?
[SPEAKER_02]: I've torn a tatter, but hold it strong.
[SPEAKER_02]: More sahaugin pop-up.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's fantastic.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, Barrel Boy, it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do we see more?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, you see them swimming towards that area.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can't go for the barrel, motherfuckers!
[SPEAKER_01]: That's where I'm headed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, I got two of them off you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know, yeah, it's perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, what are we doing?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll man the shore.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thirteen for Folsom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ten for Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty-two, Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul gets twenty-two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sixteen, Merrick.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: And these guys get a one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_05]: They all trip.
[SPEAKER_05]: Paul, you go first.
[SPEAKER_05]: In unison.
[SPEAKER_03]: I want to move.
[SPEAKER_03]: Five, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I want to shoot right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you take your crossbow and fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: You do get sneak attack with this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ooh, nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fuck them up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let them get to the barrel.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is that?
[SPEAKER_00]: I got four.
[SPEAKER_00]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, that sucks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who is next?
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I go 30 and cast and even affect these guys deeper?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know because I know that we were far away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, if you go 30, you went 60 last time.
[SPEAKER_00]: You go 30, that's 90 minus 200.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're about, I would say, 110 feet away from...
[SPEAKER_00]: Which, if I wanted to do...
[SPEAKER_00]: If you have a range of 110 feet, 120, this is about 110 feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, let me see, Fireball is a range of 20 feet, so 5, 10, 15.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if I did Fireball here, and Fireball is a range of 150 feet, so it plus gives me, so easy to make, 5, 10, 15.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I could Fireball those guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, so it's 150 feet, it's 120 feet, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
[SPEAKER_00]: Also, these guys are underwater.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, do I see them coming out?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're gonna be coming out, but right now they're moving.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I don't see them?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're swimming.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you see them, but they're swimming underwater towards the thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they might not be.
[SPEAKER_01]: So are these guys...
[SPEAKER_01]: Those two, because I can bend the fireball around them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now the question, though, is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a big spell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you only want to get two, or do you want to wait until they group up?
[SPEAKER_00]: Would it be better just to wait and go an extra thirty feet towards them?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll go an extra thirty feet towards them.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'll dash.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you are, I would say...
[SPEAKER_00]: You're 80 feet away from...
[SPEAKER_00]: So do I get to be roughly right there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not yet.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're 80 feet from this, basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you're walking on the deck now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Deck meaning... that rail?
[SPEAKER_01]: This.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'll just say that I'm 80 feet away...
[SPEAKER_01]: Merrick.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to fire on... Can I reach that one?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm shooting on the one by Tyrus, which is awesome.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fire.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know, you never use it.
[SPEAKER_02]: 20.
[SPEAKER_02]: Was it natural?
[SPEAKER_05]: Nat 20, plus 7.
[SPEAKER_05]: Plus 7, that hits.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's 2-8 damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus your damage bonus.
[SPEAKER_05]: That is 6 plus 5.
[SPEAKER_05]: 11.
[SPEAKER_05]: 14.
[SPEAKER_05]: Plus 3.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_05]: Which one did you hit?
[SPEAKER_05]: The one right by T-Money.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Doesn't kill it, but it wounds it badly.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, the arrow goes through its back on its front.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's wounded.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ooh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, Folsom.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm gonna move my sturdy.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's right here.
[SPEAKER_05]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then can I dash past Paul?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm gonna dash over to Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_00]: So count it out.
[SPEAKER_00]: So one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: You bastard!
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Could I... Can I move more this way?
[SPEAKER_00]: You can go... Let's see, you're here.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can go there.
[SPEAKER_05]: I've had that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I'll go right there instead.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, stay away from the main battle.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Vicious Mokrae is in action, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have any other
[SPEAKER_00]: Cantrip that you would want to cast?
[SPEAKER_05]: I have Message and...
[SPEAKER_05]: Pretty cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's it?
[SPEAKER_05]: That's it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Message and Vicious Mockery.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll double-check on Vicious Mockery.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm 90% sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: The detail on it's still pretty good for metal fingers.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, metal fingers.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on, Gouge.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to engage.
[SPEAKER_02]: First scimitar attack on the one that's already wounded, which is to my left, correct?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Three.
[SPEAKER_02]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_02]: And dagger.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, what's your plus?
[SPEAKER_02]: So this is with my Cutlass attack bonus.
[SPEAKER_02]: Three, so that'd be twelve.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: These guys have no other fish in a Cutlass.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which one?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, whoops.
[SPEAKER_02]: One plus a six, seven.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: On the scimitar?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he's still up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Dagger.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Plus nine is eighteen.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a one die four plus six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Finish him off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you slash him with your blade and stick him in the eye with your scimitar.
[SPEAKER_00]: He falls.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got one on me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge, Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_00]: Remember, if you move away from a living guy, he gets a free opportunity attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I could make it there easy.
[SPEAKER_01]: And do an action.
[SPEAKER_04]: I could do an action, but I couldn't do anything.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is one, two, three, so the water is 30 feet from where the barrels are at?
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: So could he grab a barrel and go to the water, even if he doesn't break the barrel open?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I mean, that would be possible.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think the biggest thing is there's a sahaugin right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, right, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he's a wounded sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's a wounded sahaugin, but if I could get all the way to here and break a barrel, I would take...
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know if you can break it this round.
[SPEAKER_01]: You might be able to grab it and run into the water.
[SPEAKER_04]: Get into the water, but I don't think I could get... Then shoot the ballista.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right here!
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, Jude gets 60!
[SPEAKER_04]: Through the barrel, through Ty.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I will, in that case, since I can't get all the way there and everything like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now you can attack him and then go 30.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's what I'm going to do.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to attack the guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I might attack on him.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, wait a second.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to use a bonus action to smite or not?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll your attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus...
[SPEAKER_04]: They're Dewey.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two plus my attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Bonus is two.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's five.
[SPEAKER_04]: So seven.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to move and let him get an opportunity attack on you?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, I do.
[SPEAKER_04]: I want to go ahead and go one, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's the opportunity attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your AC is eighteen?
[SPEAKER_00]: Eighteen, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seventeen.
[SPEAKER_00]: He hits you with his spear.
[SPEAKER_00]: And does five, six, seven points of damage to you as you move away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he still get to finish his move?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Paul, you gotta get in there on that ball.
[SPEAKER_04]: So wait, I went all the way to the barrels.
[SPEAKER_04]: I made it to the barrels, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you can bonus action grab a barrel if you want to, but you'll drop your sword and shield.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can he use the barrel as his shield?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, fully worth it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, there's nothing by him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'm going to drop the fog and pop up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do I have to drop fog and pop up?
[SPEAKER_00]: My sword and my shield?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you're going to grab a barrel this big.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gotta do it, bro!
[SPEAKER_01]: Take one for the team!
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'll do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you run up and grab the barrel in your hands, and you can move one more, I think.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to take a step towards the water?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, definitely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Set up!
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh no!
[SPEAKER_00]: It's all empty, but of course you don't know what's in it.
[SPEAKER_00]: It could be El.
[SPEAKER_00]: Could be wine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Could be whiskey.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like, win!
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, their turn.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy attacks Gouge with advantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, because he's crazy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sixteen hits you.
[SPEAKER_00]: A candy dodge!
[SPEAKER_00]: Tell me when you get the damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: One plus two is three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to do any candy dodge?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll take that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Here's his claw.
[SPEAKER_00]: Three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's his claw.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ooh, that's an uncanny dodge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uncanny dodge!
[SPEAKER_00]: Which is one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the end of his attack?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I take three?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you take five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uncanny dodge though?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, if you want to do the uncanny dodge, there are three guys right there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are they going to be able to get on him?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, but this is a reaction.
[SPEAKER_04]: His uncanny dodge is a reaction.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I'm trying to say is this is not the only attack that's going on Gouge right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are three guys right there doing their thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so how much was that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Five.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make sure I'm still up.
[SPEAKER_02]: 10, 15, 20, 25, 30, 35, 40.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You gonna take it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm?
[SPEAKER_01]: You gonna take the wound?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so he's saving his uncanny dodge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Get in there, Paul!
[SPEAKER_04]: What we didn't find out is that it takes...
[SPEAKER_04]: Two days, once we get up.
[SPEAKER_05]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_05]: This creature comes up to you.
[SPEAKER_05]: They're all like...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't feel anything yet.
[SPEAKER_00]: I feel bad, but, you know, I'm not gonna fuck that guy up.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got a slight headache.
[SPEAKER_05]: My teeth are a little more wiggly than normal.
[SPEAKER_05]: They're like, oh, wake up some diarrhea.
[SPEAKER_05]: Here's a spirit hack.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's your AC?
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh, sixteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: This hits.
[SPEAKER_00]: You take five, six, seven points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: What the hell, man.
[SPEAKER_00]: How bad are you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Only if you have any points.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I just don't have that much points.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you're wounded.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ah.
[SPEAKER_03]: You what?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hold on.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you near death?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, I'm not near death.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm just now back at like mid-18 points.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_00]: To here.
[SPEAKER_00]: He attacks you twice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's the attack on you, Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Spear.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eighteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: He hits.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Claw.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_00]: Again.
[SPEAKER_00]: Three.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six, seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uncanny dodge!
[SPEAKER_00]: Uncanny dodge!
[SPEAKER_05]: Uncanny dodge!
[SPEAKER_01]: Uncanny dodge!
[SPEAKER_03]: Uncanny dodge!
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, still not fun.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically Gouge is getting picked apart, and actually so is Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, Anish.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eighteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eighteen.
[SPEAKER_05]: What did you get?
[SPEAKER_05]: Eight?
[SPEAKER_05]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_05]: Twenty-three.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thirteen for Merrick.
[SPEAKER_05]: Six for Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_03]: Six for Tyrus?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's just like, we go to Beryl.
[SPEAKER_01]: For the critters.
[SPEAKER_01]: We go to Beryl.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, 23, Garrett.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh... Yeah, uh, one to the... You can just... Don't really matter.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can't you disengage?
[SPEAKER_02]: I ain't fucking giving up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Boom!
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to the one on the left.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's coming out of the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hoping Flute Boy can take on something here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, scimitar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come on, motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_02]: 18, 24.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's 6 plus 6.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I can't do sneak attack yet, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because there's nothing to hide behind.
[SPEAKER_00]: 10.
[SPEAKER_00]: 10 points of damage?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And dagger.
[SPEAKER_02]: 11, 20.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: 18 total, he does not go down, but basically you're slashing him up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge is involved in a slugfest with a Sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge is gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is... No, not gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge has turned us over.
[SPEAKER_00]: Folsom Jude, who wants to go first?
[SPEAKER_00]: Folsom, you go first.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: I am going to go one, two, three, four, five, and stab the sahaugin with my rapier.
[SPEAKER_00]: With your rapier?
[SPEAKER_00]: You run up and attack him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he get advantage if that guy is going the other way?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's rapier plus one.
[SPEAKER_05]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eleven, what is your plus?
[SPEAKER_05]: Plus four, and it's the rapier plus one on top of that.
[SPEAKER_05]: So it's plus five, so that's sixteen, you hit him.
[SPEAKER_05]: So one die, eight, plus two.
[SPEAKER_05]: Plus three, actually.
[SPEAKER_05]: Does the rapier plus one damage as well?
[SPEAKER_00]: Damage as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh wow, so nine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine points of damage, you stab the sahaugin from behind, and I think... No, no, no, that was the damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: You kill him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Way to go, Bard!
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, now I had dashed my last round and you said I was like 80 feet away.
[SPEAKER_01]: You are 80 feet away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I move 30 feet?
[SPEAKER_01]: And if I want to put a fireball right here and protect these two guys, can I put a fireball and like wipe those guys out?
[SPEAKER_01]: You totally can.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I'm gonna do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: That'll be my last third level spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so I'll be in range and it is...
[SPEAKER_00]: 8d6?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: They gotta make a dexterity save, so all three of them have to make a dexterity save and throw it as 8d6.
[SPEAKER_01]: I gotta make it two?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, because I can warp it around.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's in a vorker so he gets to sculpt it around.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I have sixes?
[SPEAKER_01]: I need some more sixes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So 8d3, 4, 5, 7, 8.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty, three, eight, nine, twenty-nine points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Flames!
[SPEAKER_00]: Burst around here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to save the...or do you care about that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I want to what?
[SPEAKER_00]: Save the... Yeah, if I can.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, yes, you can.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so flames burn around here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here are their saving throws.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dex saving throws.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the DC is 16.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_02]: You're doing them one at a time?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm doing all three of them at once.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which one's which?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because I want to know because... Well, I guess... That's a good point.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll do them one at a time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's that, guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_00]: 16 is the DC.
[SPEAKER_00]: He Fries.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was already almost dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: This guy.
[SPEAKER_05]: This guy want to get it back!
[SPEAKER_00]: He saves.
[SPEAKER_00]: He takes 15 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he is at 15.
[SPEAKER_00]: But he's still alive.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's still up.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's still up, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy.
[SPEAKER_05]: This guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: One is incinerated in front of you.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, if you're sitting there, he like is totally dusted as you're standing there watching the inferno go around.
[SPEAKER_00]: His spear drops to the floor.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, you get a little mouth watery because it's like, you know, barbecued fish.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't know if I get a bonus action, I'm just gonna put a thumb up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm like somewhere, like right around there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Folsom is gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: So there's still a guy here and still a guy there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I get attacked there.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, Merrick, you're next.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: How many guys have we got?
[SPEAKER_05]: We got him, him, and- He's wounded.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not wounded.
[SPEAKER_05]: Nobody else.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can see him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's weaponless and shieldless as he carries a barrel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go for it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Shoot the barrel!
[SPEAKER_05]: No.
[SPEAKER_05]: No!
[SPEAKER_05]: No, I'm shooting him.
[SPEAKER_05]: At an advantage?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not an advantage because he's long distance, but this guy can't see him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's shooting out of nowhere.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, he's still clear over there.
[SPEAKER_04]: He hasn't moved.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: And there's no one else around him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cause I forgot I have Hordebreaker, so if there's another enemy within five feet of him, I can shoot him as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: There's no one around him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Uh, seven.
[SPEAKER_05]: Seven plus... Plus seven, 14.
[SPEAKER_05]: That hits.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: One day eight.
[SPEAKER_05]: Plus three.
[SPEAKER_05]: Four.
[SPEAKER_05]: Four plus?
[SPEAKER_05]: It's four total.
[SPEAKER_05]: Four total.
[SPEAKER_00]: Four total?
[SPEAKER_00]: No way.
[SPEAKER_00]: You get a plus three.
[SPEAKER_00]: You roll the one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thirteen points of damage off that guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you win him again, but not enough to take him down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe slow.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is your dexterity?
[SPEAKER_00]: My dexterity is...
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, 15.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, you're tied with these guys, so you get to go first.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, can I, uh, I can make it to the water?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: And break this barrel?
[SPEAKER_04]: Use your action to pummel open the back barrel.
[SPEAKER_02]: He has no weapon, so he's got to either crush it or punch it.
[SPEAKER_00]: He can use his fist to open it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh-huh.
[SPEAKER_04]: And can I use this dock as cover from that guy?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm using that doc as cover, I'm into the water, cracking this barrel.
[SPEAKER_00]: You expose the contents of the barrel, which is kind of a strange pale yellowish powder.
[SPEAKER_00]: Smells something like sulfur.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Farts.
[SPEAKER_04]: Really?
[SPEAKER_04]: The dog could have fucking... We could have set the fucking dog on the island and killed all of this shit?
[SPEAKER_04]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I blow open this barrel in the water.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, and then you take it and just go like that?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh yeah, I'm just like fucking hosing myself and everything else and the water and everything.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so he flings all this powder into the thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to do it all right there?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, I want to get it as far as I'm flinging it and then about halfway I'm going to throw the barrel over
[SPEAKER_04]: Into here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you have it right there, and then you throw it over this way.
[SPEAKER_03]: This powder is also explosive, you should know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, thanks for the info now there, Paul.
[SPEAKER_04]: You do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Good thing for the fireballs coming along now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, by the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, hey, guess what, guys, you probably shouldn't.
[SPEAKER_03]: To be fair, I said that way back when we were back there with Fairwind and the other Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, hang on a second.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge, this guy attacks you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Advantage, spear.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six, four, miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: Advantage, the claw.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five, four, miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes!
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy comes up- Does he get affected by the dust?
[SPEAKER_01]: He said he was swinging- Hang on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hang on.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: He attacks you with his spear.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_00]: He sticks you in the back with a spear for it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Woohoo!
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow!
[SPEAKER_00]: You're still up?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm gonna do something.
[SPEAKER_04]: Barely, but I'm up.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then as he sticks you, it lets out this strange guttural cough.
[SPEAKER_00]: And water, bloody water starts to come out of its gills.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it crumbles down into the water with its blade.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: This creature all of a sudden kind of changes color.
[SPEAKER_00]: Its skin, which is kind of greenish, kind of turns a yellowish color as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: You might want to wash all that dust off.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm in the water, I'm, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Anish.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_05]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_05]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_05]: Seven as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: Uh, twenty-one.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, Paul, you get to go first.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is there actually- Oh wait, yeah, what is there left to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a Sahaugin right there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll just go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where's the one that went gooey?
[SPEAKER_00]: Tickle his butt.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that the one that went gooey?
[SPEAKER_00]: That one is the one that went away.
[SPEAKER_00]: The one next to you is looking sick.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, okay, looking sick.
[SPEAKER_00]: Got it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tickle his butt.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sneak attack him.
[SPEAKER_00]: 12 plus 6.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a hit, and if you want a sneak attack, you can.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is, you're using your dagger or what are you using?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm using my dagger.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's one die four plus what, two die six?
[SPEAKER_03]: One die four, yeah, two die six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: One die four plus your strength.
[SPEAKER_03]: Dexterity.
[SPEAKER_03]: Give me six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: So one, three, four, five, six, seven, that's eleven.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eleven, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you go up there and stick the guy in the stomach and he folds down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you guys are standing there on the beach, watching around, seeing if any more of them are gonna come around.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, they're probably gonna melt or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: About ten seconds go by.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it doesn't affect us.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then a body comes up to the surface.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like a sahaugin-looking body?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a sahaugin-looking body.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then another one comes up out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I'm looking for Lord Fairwind to be like... All of a sudden, dozens of bodies start popping up out in the cave out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then a shark body pops up, 40 feet long.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then a what?
[SPEAKER_00]: A shark body, a 40 foot long shark body pops up, out in the middle.
[SPEAKER_00]: It seems like something like 40 or 50 sahaugin bodies pop up in the water right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: We would have been toast.
[SPEAKER_00]: At least a dozen sharks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Any Lord Farrowind clinging onto the rocks?
[SPEAKER_00]: You see, Lord Farrowind's body does not pop up out of the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ty, grab the big shark, let's gut it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he might be in there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so here we go.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's the end of the battle.